hi everyone happy new year happy 2021.
sitting here in washington dc
uh right outside uh what is increasingly
becoming a war zone
because this week there is a hopefully
peaceful transfer of power
from one leader to another anyway let's
talk about journalism
i sort of stumbled into journalism first
i wanted to be like a cinematographer
filmmaker
then i wanted to be a diplomat and i
wanted to join the foreign service for
the united states
then i learned that i didn't want to do
either of those things and then i could
actually combine
ingredients from both to do this thing
called journalism
communicating kind of complex topics
of the day to an audience i didn't go to
journalism school i didn't formally
study this but i ended up becoming what
most would call a journalist over the
years i've learned a few things about
journalism that i want to share with you
i assign a reporter to get all the
important facts and to write the story i
also assign a news photographer to take
pictures
the recorder and photographer will work
together as a team now the reporter has
all the facts
he's ready to write his story he puts
the most important facts in the first
few sentences
then he adds the interesting details so
let's make a list here
number one objectivity is a myth there's
no such thing
as objectivity i often find myself in
these conversations where people are
just like if there was just
unbiased objective news all of our
problems in the media would just go away
that's a really attractive
idea but the more i do this the more i
realize
that objectivity isn't a thing it's a
theory
it's not a real thing you can ever
achieve every article you read
every video you watch every photo you
see was
produced by a human being who went out
and
gathered that information and then
decided what facts to put down
on paper they chose to frame the issue a
certain way
to leave out some stuff and to include
other stuff there were choices there and
those choices were the product of
a human and their biases even a
photojournalist someone who takes
pictures for newspapers presumably the
least biased type of journalism there
can be is still totally subject to bias
the way that photo is cropped and framed
and
who they decided to take a photo of and
at what time and how they decided to
expose the frame
all of those are choices objectivity is
a myth but what isn't a myth and what's
real and i think what people are sort of
getting at when they talk about
objectivity
is fairness being fair to your topic or
your subject or the other side of the
argument that you're making in your
article my old boss ezra klein used to
talk about this concept as generosity we
as journalists go out and gather a bunch
of information and facts about a thing
and then we sort of land somewhere on
what we think about that topic and our
journalism our
story is going to reflect that decision
but what you can do
as a fair journalist is you can be
generous to the other side
you can present the best version of the
other side's argument
that to me is what healthy journalism
has is generosity
to the other side but objectivity it
just
doesn't exist i experienced this in the
first season of borders when i was
in japan doing that north korea bubble
story
i clearly had a position in that story
but at the same time
i wanted to give the best version the
most generous version
of the north korean viewpoint and i
tried to
split that balance while also being
clear and assertive about the facts
that's a difficult balance but when it's
done right
it makes for better journalism number
two a lot of journalists
write for their peers and not for their
audience this is another really
useful thing that i learned from ezra
working at vox a lot of journalism is
hard to understand that's just a fact
like even now when i read the wall
street journal or the washington post or
the new york times i have a hard time
getting around some of the language and
some of the things that are happening
especially for topics that i'm sort of
new to
i've always felt this and it's always
sort of been frustrating because i'm
like
aren't you guys writing so that i
understand like i'm an educated consumer
of this news and yet i'm having a hard
time understanding like that's a problem
a lot of journalism is written for
insiders people who are
already kind of familiar with the topic
as a journalist when you're writing
about something that's kind of complex
you start to sort of get in your head
you're like man a lot of people are
going to see this and a lot of really
smart people are going to see this so if
i use
really simple language what are my peers
gonna think what are my journalist
friends down the road at the washington
post
the new york times gonna think about
this article if i don't use all the
fancy jargon if i'm explaining the
financial crisis in venezuela it's a lot
more tempting to write
something like hyperinflation has led to
the complete devaluation of the local
currency
spurring a collapse in wages which shows
my peers that i'm actually really smart
i have a master's degree in
international relations and economics
but what about my audience who knows
nothing
about hyperinflation they're left
feeling left out
and no more informed about the financial
crisis in venezuela
instead what i should do is write
something like
situation has gotten so bad in venezuela
that the money
is worth a thousand times less than it
was last year
making those who were once really rich
now struggling to find their next meal
it's still accurate it's still smart and
it's still a
an accurate assertion about what's
happening in venezuela i'm just not
using any of the jargon if my peers
judge me for that
so be it at least my audience will
understand number three
journalism has a lot of very old customs
or traditions there are a lot of old
practices and habits in journalism
that feel like gospel to a lot of people
in journalism one of the big ones that i
always run into
is that in sort of traditional
conventional journalism
we don't say the word i the journalist
is a fly on the wall
we're not there to insert ourselves our
personal character
into the story therefore we don't say
the word i
and i sort of understand the thinking
behind that even if i don't practice it
the other convention or custom mainly in
like documentary
and video journalism is that we're not
here to make things look too beautiful
beautiful b-roll evocative music
beautiful motion graphics those are for
like
the brands and the corporate people here
in journalism
we care about the story and all the
fancy stuff is just
fluff not necessary at all i disagree
with both of those
i disagree with the aversion to using i
and i disagree
with the aversion to using beautiful
imagery and b-roll in music luckily when
i came into journalism i came into an
organization that was
very eager to disrupt this old
set of customs and journalism vox really
encouraged me to experiment
thank goodness they did i was able to
start a series that was all about
showing beautiful visuals of places
around the world and it had music and it
had motion graphics
and of course it had a lot of turning
the camera on myself
and talking to the camera i was a
character in the story
and i would go to these conferences
these journalism conferences
and i would always get sort of
interrogated by these legacy news people
who are like can you really consider
this journalism and my
response was always i don't know like
you can decide i'm not here to chase the
label of journalism i'm here to tell
stories
about people and to bring big audiences
to those stories
the reality is a lot of these customs
are sort of arbitrary
and they were developed at a different
time when
information was shared differently let
me caveat
just one big thing here by saying that a
lot of these norms
and a lot of these customs and ethics
within journalism are
actually really useful the idea of
staying
honest and fact-based and accurate
and making sure that your assertions
actually have some evidence to them
i am all for that i love that there is a
very strong tradition
and burden of evidence within journalism
that says if you can't prove it
it's not real especially because a lot
of those customs which i believe are the
really important customs
of factual information are sort of going
out the window
and if you need proof of that just go
five miles away from me to the capitol
like a week ago and see how that was
covered by journalists on both sides
when it comes to the formats the oh that
guy turned the camera on himself or did
a bunch of drone shots and therefore
it's not journalism
i'm here to tell stories that have facts
and data
and characters and help inform people
if you decide to call that journalism or
not i don't really care
that's how i do it but i guess the
lesson here is that
if you're going into journalism those
are really serious
intense customs that you will come in
contact with
which gets me to my next lesson which is
number four
journalism school isn't always the best
way to get into journalism
now let me just pause for a second and
make it clear that i am not
saying don't go to journalism school
most of the people who have taught me
what i know about the craft of
journalism went to journalism school and
i am deeply grateful
thank you joss fong and others for
teaching me how to do journalism when
frankly didn't know what i was doing
when i walked in the door the first day
of box
but let me make it clear that going to
journalism school is not the only or
even the best way to get into journalism
man i've said journalism the word
journalism so many times in this video
it's starting to get to the point where
like the word feels weird to say because
i've said it so much
so anyway my critique of journalism
school is the same critique i have of
film school which is something i started
and stopped after about a year and a
half the critique for both of these
is that the institution spends so much
time focusing on
theory tradition history critique of
the old style of doing it the old way of
doing filmmaking or the old way of doing
journalism
that they don't give the students much
chance to actually
experiment and play around with like the
new versions of how this thing is being
done
we spend so much time looking back and
talking to faculty
who sort of had their heyday in like the
old days that they don't spend a lot of
time doing the type of journalism that
happens
today which is under very different
circumstances economically
politically etc so my big critique is
that there isn't enough
in the trenches experience with
journalism and that you end up getting
a sort of warped version of what you're
going to be doing and a lot of fixed
ideas that
are hard to sort of shift when you
actually get out into the real world now
there are a lot of journalism schools
who are doing
really great work in this department and
letting their students see what it's
really like i go and speak to a lot of
these journalism schools whether it's
the university of oregon or
stanford or yale or whatever it is when
i speak to students at these schools
i see an appetite from faculty to give
these students perspective
on what journalism looks like in 2021
what it looks like in this new age
of digital journalism and what are the
different versions of journalism that
one can
go into the big strength of journalism
school is that they teach you the
importance of
reporting meaning going out and
gathering facts of fairness
of facts of accuracy of evidence the
heart of journalism you learn in
journalism school
absolutely that is totally irrefutable i
believe in that but i believe that you
get a lot of that
fluff on top of the customs and how
you're supposed
to do journalism and what is and what
isn't and those fixed ideas if they
root too deeply can hinder you once you
get out into the field
go there learn like go for it but make
sure you don't get too entrenched
on what journalism is and isn't the next
lesson
is that journalism is economic in its
very nature
it has to be it is a business just
watched little women
the new one with hermione is really good
i watched little women a bunch growing
up but i never really got it and then i
watched this one and it totally made
sense and i loved it anyway there's this
amazing line
in there where she says so don't sit
there and tell me
that marriage isn't an economic
proposition because it is journalism
is an economic proposition meaning if
you're starting a journalism outlet in
the united states
you are doing so as a business you need
to keep your lights on and your doors
open
by selling something whether it's
subscriptions or whether it's ads or
whether it's some other
new version of economic value that you
can create with your journalism
you have to do that and with that comes
a certain
set of expectations and incentives that
aren't necessarily aligned with the
incentives of
telling really good stories and now of
course i've ranted about this in a
previous video called why i hate the
news
i'm not going to go into the depths of
my
thoughts on this if you want to go watch
that video you should but whenever i go
speak
at a journalism conference in europe i
always chat with them about the
economics of journalism in switzerland
or the netherlands or whatever and in
europe they've really
realized that like private media can get
out of control and can lead to some
really bad outcomes and so
they really try to buffer the media
machine
from private interests and they do so in
a pretty good job there's still private
media in europe but here in the united
states
private media is the name of the game
and the effects of these incentives
on journalism are very apparent we are
incentivized to chase
volume to chase numbers to chase like a
little bit of like what's going to get
people to click
it's hard to compete when the
information landscape
is incentivizes us to be in that
environment money usually comes from
attention
and advertising not necessarily
subscribers
who pay a monthly fee for your newspaper
and attention and traffic are not always
conducive
to telling the best story or doing the
best journalism which is a real travesty
the
best thing that took the most time the
biggest article that has the most
information is not actually the most
valued
among the attention economy but anyway
i'm not here to
lament human psychology i do offer two
pieces of hope to this capitalistic
incentive of the media quandary number
one is that
there are still really great outlets
that publish really in-depth media
and that you just have to pay money to
and by doing so
you shield the need for them to have to
just
chase pure volume one of my favorite
outlets of all time and where i get most
of my news
and my ways of thinking about the world
is a british weekly magazine called the
economist and i pay for it i like to
consume media
that i know was crafted by the
incentives of serving me
the payne customer as opposed to serving
a different master
which is an advertiser who will keep
them afloat there's still a lot of
amazing media that happens through
advertiser revenue it just is a fact
most media had to pivot to that but more
and more those incentives are
pushing media into more sensationalized
polarized places okay my second piece of
hope here
is that when i joined vox we were just
sort of taking off we had less than 100
000 subscribers on youtube it was like
the early days and there was this
hypothesis among the whole organization
which was like
a few dozen people that if we could tell
really good
stories and explain really complicated
things to people
that we would actually win the views
game like people would actually come
to us instead of the funny cat video
because they actually want to understand
people actually want to engage with good
information and it turns out that that
hypothesis was
totally correct the most popular videos
i ever made at vox
one a six minute explainer of a complex
middle eastern war
really complicated but got hundreds of
millions of views and another really
popular video i made was a 10 minute
video
explaining the housing policy crisis and
tax law in hong kong like some of the
most boring but
important information you could ever
think of but because they were presented
in a way
that people could access it actually
made them really popular and people said
yes i want to understand
what's going on with the syrian civil
war because everyone's talking about it
and i don't understand it i will sit
through this six minute video and that
video by the way took off not on youtube
but on facebook
like the place where people's attention
is apparently the lowest and where
people are just there to
click on whatever's sensational that's a
problem that's happening but you can
still get people to
watch really in-depth stuff if it's well
told and well presented so that that's a
hopeful thing to my to my little lament
about the economics of journalism man
i'm getting deep right now i'm getting
like deep into my theories of journalism
yeah yeah this is great this is good
let's get on to the next lesson
number six good writing is rare
and beautiful what i've learned in
journalism is that the difference
between someone
really connecting with a story and not
connecting with a story is just a few
words
good writing whether it's for a video or
a text-based article it can bring you
into a story it can illuminate a topic
it can
humanize a character it's really
important i wasn't very good at writing
when i started at vox
and over the years i had some really
good story editors who would look at my
writing and
help me reshape it and simplify it and
make it more concise
and make it clearer i am grateful for
the people who taught me how to write
because a lot of the videos you see on
this channel yeah there is
beautiful maps and there's fancy footage
and there's lots of drone shots and
whatever but at the end of the day
behind all of that the reason why you're
interested in watching those videos
is because i put a major priority on
writing i spend so much time
choosing my words so that every story i
tell
sinks in on the other side when you're
listening and that's because good
journalism
is good writing at the end of the day
and it's incredibly important
if you want to get better at writing i
have a book for you i'm going to put the
link in the description if i forget to
do that call me out in the comments
because i don't want to forget because i
want to tell you about this book i mean
i could just say it right now and then
you could go find it but oh but
if i put it in this link in the
description i could make it an affiliate
link and then i could get
money every time you click it man the
incentives of the
21st century economy are just plain on
my mind right now
oh gosh okay the last lesson here good
journalism is important now hear me out
on this this might sound trite but i've
learned over the years that
journalism is hard to go out and gather
information that doesn't exist in the
world
and to communicate it to the rest of the
world
is is hard our country these past few
months has shown me
just how important and how sort of
delicate good journalism can be
facts don't matter for a lot of people
these days
and before you know it you can have a
person in power
creating fake stories about an election
and you can have a news outlet that
claims to be doing journalism
jump on board with that narrative and
make up
facts to support it that's scary good
journalism the stuff where people are
going out and actually
scrutinizing evidence and presenting
robust
arguments to an audience that is
scrupulous
back towards them and there's a
discussion in discourse
that's rare and special here in the
united states we call it the fourth
estate this institution
a free press that keeps our leaders
honest
keeps our corporations honest keeps our
society together and honest there will
always be people
and institutions whose sole purpose is
to gain journalism
offers a spotlight or a watchdog
on those actors on those institutions
and because of that it's really really
important
i am very very grateful for those
journalists especially right now
at this time in history where covering
the facts is
so freaking important for keeping our
society
peaceful and together and honest and
working
i just i'm grateful for the good
journalism that's happening the people
are out there hustling
and i lament the hostility that has been
shown
towards those people and i hope we can
move on
and get back to facts and truth thanks
for watching
this video is sponsored by squarespace
which is an all-in-one platform where
you
can create any sort of online presence
you want whether it's portfolio
for your videos or for your photography
or you are launching a business
and you want to have an online presence
that isn't just a website but also
a place where you can do email campaigns
and seo so that your website shows up on
search
or integration with social media
whatever it is squarespace is a place
where you can create
online presence that is beautiful and
it's really quick and easy
it's like a drag-and-drop few minutes
and you could have a little website live
on the internet i
love squarespace have for a long time
and i'm grateful that they
support this channel there's a link in
my description where if you click it it
helps support this channel but it also
gives you 10 off your first purchase at
squarespace whether it is hosting space
or a domain name
or whatever you get 10 off if you click
that link thank you squarespace for
sponsoring this video
uh thank you all for watching thank you
patrons
like always like i've now had a patreon
for like maybe six months or maybe more
and i'm just i sort of thought like man
the patrons are gonna be there for a few
minutes
and then like after month two they're
all just gonna flee but they haven't and
i'm so
grateful because it helps support my
work i have some
very zesty videos coming out in the next
couple weeks get ready for those just
telling you
like how the us stole the middle east
part two i know you've all been asking
for it
it's coming all right see you all in the
next one
have a good day happy new year bye this
is the plan for page ten then he writes
a headline a title for the story
then the printed story is checked
against the original story to make
certain that there are no mistakes
warning light the presses are starting
to roll newspapers are sold on the
streets newspapers are delivered to
homes
and they are red everywhere
i like my job helping to bring the news
to our community